we are one people  one world and together we can and we  must  create a future for those who will  inherit the earth  and we need to do it now  louis armstrong said it isn't the world  that's so bad  it's what we are doing to it and imagine  what a wonderful world it would be  if we just gave it a chance  [Music]  i see trees of green  red roses too  i see them blue  [Music]  for me and you  and i think to myself  what a wonderful word  i see skies of blue  and clouds of white  the bright blessed days  the dark sacred nights  and i think to myself  what a wonderful world  the colors of the rainbow  so pretty in the sky  are also on the faces of the people  passing by i see friends shaking hands  saying  how do you do  they're really saying i  love you  i hear babies cry  i watch them grow  they'll learn much more than i  ever know and i  think to myself  what a wonderful word  [Music]  yes i think  to myself  what a wonderful  word